[Music]
[Narrator: The United States Public Health Service as it exists today is the product of experience
extending over a period of nearly 150 years.
It was originally created as a Marine Hospital
service for the purpose of providing medical
care to American merchant seaman.
The Marine Hospital service was established
by an Act of Congress signed by the second
president of the United States, John Adams,
on July 16, 1798.
This service was originally supported by a
tax on American merchant seaman, but this
tax was later abolished.
The tax was collected by the collector of
customs of the Treasury Department, and the
Marine Hospital Service came under the jurisdiction
of that department where it remains today.
The first Marine Hospital, located at Norfolk,
Virginia, was purchased from that state in 1881.
The second was built in Boston, Massachusetts
(unintelligible)
and some of the medical personnel were utilized
by both the Union and the Confederacy for
the care of the (unintelligible) wounded of
the military forces.
It frequently happened that the medical officers
of the early Marine Hospitals were the first
physicians to diagnose such diseases as cholera,
yellow fever, and smallpox, which seriously
endangered the public health at ports of entry.
As time went on, the work of the Service became
of such increasing importance to the public
health of the country that Congress gradually
extended its duties until it became in function
a federal health service.
Recognizing the value of mobility and military
discipline in an organization which had to
combat epidemic diseases,
Congress authorized the organization of the
Marine Hospital Service along military lines,
with officers holding commissions and grades
similar to those of officers of the Medical
Departments of the Army and the Navy.
In 1912 the name of the Service was changed
to that borne by this organization today,
the United States Public Health Service.
The Public Health Service is administered
by the Surgeon General, who is responsible
directly to the Secretary of the Treasury,
to Congress, and to the President of the United States.
We will now hear the Surgeon General briefly
outline the work of the Public Health Service.
Although the first responsibility for public
health rests upon the states and localities
in our country, the federal government, through
the Public Health Service, does much to prevent
disease and improve the health of all the
people.
This is done in many ways.
One very skilled group of men and women (unintelligible)
of disease and means of preventing it.
Other Service officers guard the ports to
prevent the introduction of disease from abroad.
Others have the duty of preventing and halting
the spread of infections within our own territory.
Under the provisions of the recently enacted
Social Security Act, the Public Health Service
is cooperating with every state and territory
in the development, in those states and territories,
of a national health program.
This cooperative work between the federal,
state, and local governments should provide
new standards of health for the people.
In addition, the manufacture of all serums
and vaccines sold in the country is carefully
supervised by the Public Health Service.
Studies are carried out concerning drug addiction
and mental hygiene.
It conducts Marine Hospitals in which are
treated American sailors.
In addition, this Service keeps in constant
touch with health conditions throughout the
world, through weekly reports from every consular
officer.
It encourages health education in various
problems of disease prevention.
In what follows, you will see, in much more
detail, the ways in which this organization operates for human service.
[Music]
For centuries it has been well known that
epidemic diseases follow the lines of commerce and travel.
During colonial times and in the early days
of our republic, the introduction of yellow
fever, smallpox, cholera, and other diseases
from foreign countries by ship was by no means uncommon
Epidemics of yellow fever from this source
occurred as late as 1798 in New York, in Baltimore
as late as 1832, and in Philadelphia as late
as 1853.
Many outbreaks of smallpox and cholera were
the result of cases brought in by vessels.
The danger of introduction of diseases from
abroad has paralleled in growth the remarkable
development of transportation on the sea,
on the land,
and in the air.
The transportation of disease has been as
much facilitated by improved mechanical methods
as has the transportation of persons or property.
Maritime quarantine was at first undertaken
by the states and cities, but is now administered
by the Public Health Service at all the ports
of the United States and its possessions.
To perform these functions, the Service has
been given quarantine jurisdiction over all
ships and all persons, both citizens and aliens,
coming into American ports from abroad.
In its quarantine work, the United States
Public Health Service maintains a fleet of
trim and speedy boarding tugs, which carry
the quarantine officers out to the vessels
arriving at United States ports.
When a vessel arrives at quarantine, the medical
quarantine officer, a nurse, and an inspector
go out to it in one of these boarding tugs
so well known to seaman and ocean travelers.
They draw alongside the vessel and go aboard.
The quarantine officer meets the ship’s
doctor and the purser.
The purser turns over to him certain records of the vessel's voyage for inspection,
especially the bill of health and health record en route, which shows all cases of illness occurring
on board during the trip.
Ah, the list here shows a suspicious case
of illness in a member of the crew.
Let’s see now what happens.
The quarantine officer is taken to the sick
bay in the crew's quarters to examine the patient.
His experience and training in the detection
of the symptoms of rare as well as common diseases,
tells him that this patient is suffering
from typhus fever.
He orders the patient to be removed from the
vessel,
and put aboard the quarantine tug to be taken
ashore.
All persons who have been in contact with
the patient, and thus have been exposed
to the disease, are also ordered on board the tug.
The patient and the contacts are taken to
the detention hospital, in this instance,
Hoffman Island in New York Harbor.
On their arrival, the sick patient is taken
directly to the hospital.
Here he is given appropriate treatments and
cared for until he has recovered.
Every facility is made available in such cases,
both for the benefit of the patient himself,
and for the protection of others.
As this happens to be a case of Old World
typhus fever, which is known to be spread
by the body louse, the contacts, those who
have had association with the patient
during the voyage, are first taken to the delousing plant.
Here they must remove all of their clothing,
Thoroughly sprayed with soap and water.
Next they are sent under the shower.
And finally, each one is sprayed with an insecticide
that kills any lice or nits that may still
remain in their hair.
The clothing of these contacts is placed in
net bags, and these bags are sent to the fumigating room.
This clothing, together with the baggage of
the contacts, is placed in fumigating chambers
where it is thoroughly disinfested.
If necessary, the contacts are isolated in
the detention hospital for observation.
Every precaution is taken by the quarantine
officers to prevent the introduction of disease
into the United States.
When the quarantine work has been completed,
and the ship declared free from danger, the
medical officers of the Public Health Service
then turn to the inspection of immigrants.
This scene shows the well-known immigration
station at Ellis Island New York.
During the busy period of a few years ago,
more prospective citizens of this country
arriving from abroad entered through this
world-renowned station than through any other
port of the country.
In past years thousands of aliens arrived
at Ellis Island daily, and each one had to
undergo an examination at the hands of the
medical officers of the Public Health Service.
In past times too, many of them arrived only
to be turned back at our very gate, because
of mental or physical defects.
This was a necessary, but somewhat cruel procedure,
and caused many heart aches, untold hardships,
and much unnecessary expense.
To avoid this condition, a new system was
inaugurated by international consent in 1925,
since which year, intending immigrants have
been examined in foreign countries by Public
Health Service officers who are assigned to
American consulates for this purpose.
The prospective immigrant makes application
through the American consul, who, if the applicant
comes within the quota prescribed by Congress,
arranges for an examination by the Public
Health Service medical officer.
If the applicant passes these physical and
mental tests successfully, there is little
chance that he will be refused admittance
later.
[Historians have recorded that the Bubonic
Plague or the "Black Death" almost depopulated
Europe during the Middle Ages.]
[Webster on pestilence] Among other old records,
Webster's book on pestilence gives vivid descriptions
of the many ravages of bubonic plague.
[Panning shots of book pages]
This disease is constantly present in the
Orient, and this fact makes it an ever present
threat to the United States and its possessions.
The germ that causes bubonic plague is carried
by fleas that live on rats and other rodents.
Rats are great travelers, and vessels at wharves
must use rat guards to keep them from  coming aboard.
Notice how this rat balances himself with
his tail.
Now he attempts to clear the rat guard.
Will he succeed?
It looks like he'll make it.
No, he admits defeat and he returns to the
wharf.
Yellow fever, the fearful Yellow Jack which
once struck terror to the South, is one of
the best examples of a dread disease now almost
entirely wiped out by science.
It is transmitted principally by a particular
kind of mosquito.
With the mosquitoes that transmit the disease
exterminated, yellow fever is eliminated.
Although yellow fever has been banished from
our shores since 1905, it still exists in
South America and Africa.
And recent development in air travel again
make it a menace to the United States.
To combat this menace, the yellow fever mosquito
must be eliminated from ships and airplanes,
and infected persons must be detected and
isolated.
Although the mosquitoes which spread yellow
fever usually fly but a relatively short distance,
they have been carried by airplanes for thousands
of miles.
It's only by the exercise of the utmost care
and constant watchfulness that this dangerous,
ever-threatening disease is kept outside our
borders.
When there arrives at a port of entry an airplane
which might bring in the yellow fever mosquito,
the passengers and crew are inspected for
symptoms of the disease.
An important part of the inspection is the
taking of the temperature for evidence of fever.
The plane is gone over thoroughly with a vacuum
cleaner to recover any yellow fever mosquitoes
that might be aboard.
Then the cabin and all enclosed spaces in
the plane are sprayed with insecticide that
destroy these dangerous pests.
The opening of air routes to the Orient has
created serious problems in preventing the
introduction of diseases, particularly cholera
and smallpox, into Hawaii and the United States.
[Music]
When the country was small, travel was slow
and distances in travelled time were much
greater than they are today.
Then there was less need for action on the
part of the federal government itself in preventing
the spread of epidemics.
But with the increased proclivity of travel,
the expansion in territories,
and the concentration of populations, this
work became important.
With increase in interstate traffic, the need
for uniform quarantine regulations became apparent.
And by the consent of the states, and under
the commerce clause of the Constitution,
Congress provided for federal control of both interstate
and international quarantine.
The sanitary control over all water supplies
used for drinking or culinary purposes on
interstate carriers is one of the activities
of the Public Health Service in connection
with the prevention of the interstate spread
of disease.
It is obvious that this is a tremendous task.
The water included in these supplies comes
from almost 3,000 sources.
In this work, the cooperation of state and
city health authorities is given to the Public
Health Service.
In taking supplies of drinking and culinary
water onboard vessels, connections are made
directly to the supply pipes.
And the possibility of contamination of the
water during this process is thereby reduced to a minimum.
Here we see a supply of drinking water being
taken aboard a steamship at one of our ports.
The same sanitary precautions are carried
out when drinking water is taken aboard trains.
Frequent inspections are made of this procedure.
The passenger can therefore feel a sense of
security when he quenches his thirst from
the water cooler,
or drinks water with his meals in the dining
car.
The fight against bubonic plague is a fight
against the rat.
He must be trapped, poisoned, starved out,
built out - everything must be done to rout this animal.
The rat has been called man’s most destructive
and dangerous enemy.
He is certainly a most dangerous pest in the
case of bubonic plague.
He is sturdy, furtive, and crafty, and he
readily matches his cunning against that of to a minimum.
The rat catcher must know the habits of this
animal, and it is only with such knowledge,
combined with actual experience,
that he can qualify as an expert in what may
indeed be called a specialized field.
The rats are tagged to show the locality in
which they are caught, and are then sent to
the laboratory for examination.
Some of the rats that are taken alive are
put into bags to preserve for identification
and examination of any fleas that they may
harbor.
Here we see a sample day's catch of rats in
one of our large cities.
At the laboratory, the rats are combed for
fleas, and their fleas are collected for study
and for testing to determine whether or not
they are infected with bubonic plague.
In certain western states, plague has spread
from rats to ground squirrels, and the fight
against these animals is being constantly
carried on there.
[Music]
The following are typical scenes of the regions
in the east central sections of this country
in which trachoma is chiefly found.
In these rural sections, life was somewhat
primitive, and the sanitary conditions were
conducive to the spread of the disease because
of the habits and customs of the people.
They did not know that trachoma was spread
by means of the hands, and by towels and handkerchiefs,
and other articles which may carry the discharges
from the eyes.
Simply described, trachoma is a chronic infectious
disease of the lining membrane of the eyelid.
If the lids are turned back, a number of small
granular bodies resembling Sago grains will
be noticed.
The disease produces a roughened condition
of the inside of the lid which irritates the
front of the eyeball, causing an inflammation
which often leads to blindness.
For many years, the Public Health Service
has conducted a campaign against this ancient disease.
As early as 1912, Dr. John McMullen of the
Public Health Service was sent to Kentucky
to make a survey of the situation there.
"Dr. McMullen, what was found in Kentucky
and what was done there?"
"Well, more than 18,000 persons were examined
in 1912, and between 7 and 8 percent were found to have trachoma.
Many had already been blinded by the disease.
Many others remained in dark rooms concealing
their eyes with their arms.
Some had not seen light for months, while
many cases had existed for years.
In checking up some years later, the changes
were remarkable.
Instead of many sore-eyed people, and the
almost universal practice of wearing colored
glasses observed during the first survey,
scarcely colored glass was seen,
and few cases of active trachoma.
From the standpoint of humane and economic
considerations, there is no way to estimate
what this trachoma work has been worth.
Much of the work was done in mountain regions,
where roads even now are not good.
Usually medical officers traveled by horseback,
and often they had to walk.
The work has now been turned over to the States."
Instead of painful and sightless eyes to destroy
the joys of youth, we now have the precious
gift of sight.
The future must be dreary to one destined
to live in darkness.
Fortunately this boy was discovered in time.
Instead of blindness added to other infirmities
of old age, we have the ability to assume
an economic role in family affairs.
Numerous outbreaks of typhoid fever have followed
the use of shellfish grown in contaminated waters.
This was a danger that could be combated
by examination of the waters where oysters were grown
and forbidding the interstate shipment of
oysters originating in areas, the sanitary
conditions of which, were not approved by
the Public Health Service.
Because oysters from beds in contaminated
waters will not be certified, and shucking
plants and canneries are required to be conducted
under proper sanitary conditions,
the consumer can now enjoy this seafood with
a greater sense of security than formerly.
[Music]
An act of Congress authorizes an annual conference
between the Surgeon General and the state
health officers to discuss important health
matters.
Here the Surgeon General opens a recent conference.
"This annual conference of state and territorial
health officers will come to order.
I am delighted to greet you here today.
One of the most significant events in public
health which has occurred in our lifetime
transpired last month, when President Roosevelt
signed a bill appropriating funds to launch the health security program.
This bill and the funds authorized under it
offer a great promise to the people of this
country for better health.
It is your task and my task to see that this
promise becomes a realization.
It is to discuss the detailed means by which
we may obtain the objectives held forth in
the Social Security Act that this conference
will be concerned.
I welcome your advice.
These conferences provide opportunities for
planning effective methods for state and federal
cooperation in attacking health problems of
mutual concern.
For many years, the Public Health Service
has cooperated with the state health officers
in an effort to develop and improve state
and local health work.
When necessary, experienced Service officers
are assigned as shown here, for periods of
time to aid state and local health departments
in their special health problems.
Funds made available by Congress have been
matched by state and local agencies and used
to develop local health services.
Under the Social Security Act, provisions
for this cooperative aid to these health services has been greatly extended.
[Music.]
The city health officer of a western city
receives a telephone call.
He picks up the receiver and finds it is from
a local physician.
This physician has a case the symptoms of
which resemble epidemic encephalitis, but
there are some features which make this diagnosis
uncertain.
The city health officer remarks that he is
greatly concerned, as he has had several similar
cases recorded in the past few days.
The city health officer decides to notify
the state health officer.
He calls him by telephone and outlines the
local situation.
The state health officer immediately reports
to the Surgeon General and asks him for aid.
The city health officer calls an assistant
and instructs him to consult with the local
physician; he is definitely alarmed.
A little later a telegram is received from
the Surgeon General.
After the Public Health Service officers have
conducted a preliminary investigation, they
call a conference to discuss the situation.
"Gentlemen this epidemic is growing.
At least fifty new cases are being reported
daily.
We must encourage close, harmonious cooperation
between ourselves, as representatives of the
Public Health Service, and the city, county,
and state health authorities.
The local medical schools have made available
their laboratories and other facilities."
"What will be our policy as regards information
for the general public?"
"The city health departments are notifying
the public frankly of the situation.
Business must proceed as usual.
There must be no panic."
"There is an unusual plague of mosquitoes
just now.
How long has that been connected to this outbreak?"
"We’ll test that theory as fairly as possible."
The mosquito tests were conducted on prison
inmates who voluntarily submitted themselves
as laboratory animals.
After these experiments were made, another
conference was called to discuss the results.
"Dr. Williams, what are your results so far?"
"The mosquito apparently does not transmit
this particular disease, however our investigations
must be continued in other directions.
The epidemic, despite all that has or has
not been done, is subsiding.
We will transfer our studies to the National
Institute of Health in Washington."
As result of intensive studies at the laboratory,
it was concluded that the disease was due
to a virus, and several important new facts
regarding it were deduced from these investigations.
In preventing diseases spread through unclean
milk, a safe milk supply is essential.
Tuberculosis, (unintelligible) undulant fever,
typhoid fever,
and other diseases are spread through contaminated
milk.
The Public Health Service feels that clean
milk, properly pasteurized, is the only safe milk to drink,
and it has conducted studies to determine
the efficiency of pasteurization procedures.
These precautions assure a safe and clean
milk supply to the ultimate consumer, that
is, if ultimate sanitary precautions are observed
by the ultimate consumers themselves.
Another form of assistance to and cooperation
with the states is special aid in times of emergency.
The disastrous floods which frequently occur
in the United States illustrate an emergency
that may arise suddenly.
During these floods, the states frequently
request the help of the sanitary engineers
of the Public Health Service in providing
emergency purification and protection for
town and city water supplies in the affected
areas.
These requests for aid are met with prompt
response.
In many instances, water purification machines
are quickly dispatched to the affected areas,
and are put into operation by the sanitary
engineers.
As the water is pumped into the reservoirs
or distributing systems,
it is treated with chlorine to make it safe
for human consumption.
[Music]
In the
fight against disease from a public health standpoint,
it is fundamentally important
to know when, where, in what numbers, and
under what conditions various diseases are
occurring.
The Public
Health Service records the important communicable
diseases on charts which show their seasonal
prevalence.
Note on these charts how closely
the cases for different years follow the same
general seasonal patterns.
Each separate line
across the chart represent a year for the particular disease.
The Service maintains an intelligence office
regarding the occurrence of epidemic diseases
in the United States and foreign countries,
and reports are received weekly from all American consuls.
Their wide distribution is shown on the map.
Whenever there's an outbreak of a quaratinable
disease anywhere in the world, the American
consul at that place promptly cables this
information to Washington.
Information is also obtained from many other
sources.
From local health officers and state health
officers who report regularly by telegram,
and on cards like the card shown here.
Reports are also received from officers of
the Public Health Service stationed abroad.
Health officers of foreign governments, and
international health organizations such as
the International Office of Public Health,
the Health Section of the League of Nations,
and the Pan American Sanitary Bureau.
The information so collected is compiled and
published and is used by quarantine officers
of the Public Health Service, by our own local
state health authorities, and by other governments
throughout the world.
[Music]
Dr. L.S. Rowe, Director General of the Pan
American Union, addresses a recent conference:
"Gentlemen of the conference: at this, your
closing session, I want to express to you,
individually and collectively, the deep appreciation
of the Pan American Union for the privilege
of having had you with us during the period
of your deliberations.
It is no exaggeration to say that the Third
Pan American Conference of Directors of Health
marks a distinct step forward in that struggle
of the nations of this continent
to improve the conditions of life, to eliminate
the causes of disease, and to augment the
efficiency of the masses of the people.
I wish therefore to congratulate you, and
at the same to time assure you that in the
future, as in the past, you may count on the
earnest and enthusiastic cooperation of everyone
associated with the Pan American Union."
Dr. H.S. Cumming, Director General of the Pan American
Sanitary Bureau now speaks:
"Gentlemen, as Director of the Pan American
Sanitary Bureau and President of your conference,
for which honor I thank you, I want to join
Dr. Rowe,
in expressing our appreciation to you for
leaving your important administrative functions
and to your respective governments for sending
you to this, the most successful sanitary
conference we’ve had.
A point of progress reported by you and your
countries, practical plans formulated, is
by far the most successful conference we’ve
ever had.
I wish you Godspeed back to your respective
homes."
[[Music]
Scientific studies dealing with the diseases
of man were made by the Public Health Service
as early as 1886.
These studies have gradually expanded until
today the research of the Public Health Service
on the cause, method of spread, and means
of prevention of disease, is among the most
important work that it performs.
A research laboratory for the Public Health
Service called the Hygienic Laboratory, was
established in 1901.
In 1930, Congress changed its name to the
National Institute of Health.
At this famous institute in Washington, D.C.,
most of the investigative work of the Public
Health Service is conducted.
The diseases and conditions studied by the
Service include a long list.
Heart disease is public enemy number one.
It is first on the list of causes of death.
More than 300,000 persons die each year in
the United States from this cause.
[Principal causes of death in the United States.
Heart disease, cancer, apoplexy (cerebral
hemorage, etc.), nephritis (Brights Disease)]
The electrocardiograph has aided greatly in
the study and diagnosis of heart disease.
Next in importance to the cause of death is
cancer.
This disease results in the death of about
135,000 people in the United States annually.
Malaria is still an important public health
problem in at least 16 states of the Union.
This mosquito born disease exacts a toll of
sickness of more the 2 million cases annually.
This patient is having a malarial chill.
The fight against malaria is the fight against
the malaria mosquito.
The prevention of mosquito breeding by seeing
that no containers are left lying around to
catch and hold water, and thus provide breeding
places for mosquitoes, and by eliminating
all refuse piles, insofar as possible.
In certain regions effective mosquito control
has been accomplished by dusting water areas
with a poisonous mixture.
This dusting is done from trucks,
by hand dusting machine,
and by airplanes according to the conditions
met with.
Another effective method employed is the killing
of larvae, or wiggle tails, by the oiling
of stagnant water.
Other preventive measures include ditching
for draining and keeping mosquitoes out of
the home by screening.
The protection of the health of the industrial
worker has become a matter to which much attention
has been given.
New manufacturing processes have frequently
introduced new hazards to the health of workers.
The control of occupational disease has come
within the province of the physician and the engineer.
In many industries, dust has been found to
be a serious hazard to the health of the employees,
and exhaustive studies of the various types
of dust in industry have been made by the
Public Health Service.
Dusts are collected at the plant and atmospheric
and other data are recorded.
These dust samples are then taken to the laboratory,
where they are carefully examined to determine
the concentration, the size distribution,
and the chemical and other characteristics
of the particles.
This young lady is seen making a dust count
from a sample that was taken at one of the plants.
The Public Health Service has conducted studies
on the mottled enamel of teeth, a disfiguring
condition caused by an excessive amount of
fluorine in the drinking water of certain
areas of the United States.
These studies have shown that mottled enamel
is more prevalent in this country than had
been realized.
The Public Health Service conducts studies
on stream pollution, a subject of growing
importance with our constantly increasing
and concentrating population.
New problems have arisen from the increase
of human waste discharge into streams but
also from the increase and changing types
of industrial waste.
[Public health aspects of venereal diseases]
From a public health standpoint the venereal
diseases are one of the most important problems
confronting those whose duty it is to conserve
the health of our nation.
Special laboratories are devoted by the Public
Health Service to the study of various phases
of this subject.
One day simultaneous surveys of all sources
of treatment have been conducted by the Public
Health Service in representative areas of
the United States covering approximately one
fourth of the entire population of the country.
Estimates derived from these surveys indicate
that more than a million and a half new cases
of the venereal diseases seek treatment anually
in this country.
Cooperative studies conducted by the Public
Health Service with five of the leading venereal
disease clinics in this country indicate that
syphilis is largely curable.
To obtain recovery however treatment must
be started within the first year of the disease.
The Public Health Service cooperates with
state and local health departments in the
development of campaigns directed against
the venereal diseases.
[Background music playing]
From time immemorial, the Law of the Sea has required vessels to provide
medical attention for their seamen.
This was a difficult matter for the owners
of ships in the early days of the republic.
Therefore in order to encourage its struggling
merchant marines, Congress established the
Marine Hospital Service in 1798 to relieve
the ships of this burden.
The first Marine Hospital in Boston, which
was the first General Hospital in that city,
furnished hospital care for sailors from some
of the famous war sloops and frigates of  the war of 1812.
Today there are 25 modern, thoroughly equipped
hospitals in this service located within the United States.
These hospitals have an aggregate bed capacity
of approximately 6,000 beds and give treatment
to about 300,000 persons annually, while almost
as many more apply each year for other service
including physical examination.
New marine hospitals have recently been built
in Baltimore, Cleveland, Detroit, Galveston,
Memphis, New Orleans, Norfolk, San Francisco,
and Seattle.
The Marine Hospital at Stapleton, New York,
which is the one shown here, has been enlarged
to make it a 1,000 bed institution.
These hospitals are professionally staffed
by medical officers both competent and humane
secured by examination and selection.
Only qualified graduate nurses, professional
dietitians, and skilled therapeutic aides are employed.
These hospitals have all the specialized services:
eye, ear, nose and throat;
a thoroughly equipped x-ray department;
dental department with the
most modern equipment
hydrotherapy; physiotherapy;
venereal disease; and some have a psychiatric
service.
They are provided with the most modern appliances
for the diagnosis and treatment of disease.
Dental treatment is furnished at all Marine
Hospitals by dental officers.
Most of the patients entering, especially
the merchant seamen, are suffering from septic mouth conditions.
With the elimination of dental infection,
many remarkable recoveries have been reported.
The facilities of the marine hospitals are
available without cost to American seamen
employed onboard any registered, enrolled,
or licensed vessel of the United States;
to officers and enlisted men of the Coast
Guard;
to officers and crews of vessels of the lighthouse
service;
to certain keepers and assistant keepers of the lighthouses;
to immigrants detained at the immigration
stations;
to seamen from vessels belonging to the United States Army;
to beneficiaries of the United States Employees
Compensation Commission;
to members of the Civilian Conservation Corps
in various sections of the country;
to patients of the United States Veterans
Administration;
and to persons afflicted with leprosy.
This is the National Leprosarium at Carville,
Louisiana.
(unintelligible) for license as pilots, other
officers of vessels of United States registry,
and lighthouse keepers, must pass an examination
conducted by medical officers of the Public Health Service.
These examinations are for vision, for color
blindness, and for hearing.
The service must also pass upon the physical
ability of sailors qualifying as able-bodied seamen.
Regulations require all ships officers be
versed in first aid, therefore the Public
Health Service has organized courses of instruction
for such candidates in a number of the  larger ports.
Not only does the Service furnish medical
aid to the Coast Guard, but it also sends
its medical officers with the cruising cutters
on the North Atlantic ice patrol to furnish
medical care to the officers and crews of
these vessels.
The Service also sends medical officers with
the Bering Sea's seal patrols.
The Coast Guard makes an annual cruise along
the coast of Alaska.
Medical and dental officers of the Service
are sent on this cruise.
They give medical examinations and treatment
to the natives.
These include dental treatment and extraction.
This is the only medical service available
to many of these native Alaskans.
The National Leprosarium, which is a Marine
Hospital at Carville, Louisiana, has under
treatment more than 300 patients who are lepers.
The Leprosarium has an administration building
and a main hospital.
Treatment by the various methods and agents
used has yielded most encouraging results
and there have been many recoveries or arrested
cases.
During the last ten years, over 150 patients
have been discharged to their homes no longer
a menace to the public health, and the leprosy
arrested.
Sports are provided by baseball diamonds and
tennis courts, and the younger patients greatly
enjoy these outdoor recreational activities.
The cottages for the patients are comfortable
and are provided with ground for gardens in
which many of the patients take much delight.
Life for these unfortunate persons is made
as comfortable and as pleasant as possible.
In the attractive inner court two leper children
may be seen playing around the pool.
Medical aid to vessels without a physician
has been made possible by the development of radio.
Frequently, men are injured or suddenly develop
an acute illness on board ships far out at sea.
If there is no physician aboard, the Public
Health Service is notified by radio.
Many lives are saved each year thanks to this
radio service.
"[Hold Chatham] radio for medical advice."
"Aye, aye, captain."
[Morse code signals being sent]
The message from the vessel is received by
a commercial radio station which immediately
relays it by telephone to the nearest Marine
Hospital.
"Seamen suffering from sore throat for two
days.
Now has temperature 104.
Slight cough.
Face flushed.
Appears seriously ill.
Request medical advice.
Signed, Master of SS Columbia."
"Send this reply: man apparently has acute
tonsillitis.
Put him to bed on liquid diet.
Have him drink cold water freely.
Use hot alkaline gargle every two hours.
Give 10 grains of aspirin every three hours
for four doses.
Report progress in 12 hours.
Sign this, 'U.S. Marine Hospital'"
"Very well sir."
A merchant seaman may have been suddenly attacked
by illness on approaching port.
Here again, the medical officers of the Marine
Hospital are notified by radio.
But in this case an ambulance is sent from
the hospital to the dock to meet the boat.
The patient is taken off the vessel on a stretcher.
He is placed in the ambulance and rushed to
the Marine Hospital.
On arriving at the hospital, he is taken directly
to the ward for examination and diagnosis.
The medical officers examine him carefully,
and with the aid of the history of the case
that is furnished them, they make their diagnosis.
In this instance, it is definitely an acute
attack of appendicitis.
The patient must be operated on at once.
He is therefore taken to the operating room
where the troublesome appendix is removed.
[background music playing]
An act of Congress requires that the medical
care in federal penal and correctional institutions
be furnished by the Public Health Service.
The prisoners are given thorough physical
examinations: eye, ear, nose, and throat;
chest; dental; and other examinations.
They are also given various types of mental
tests.
These mental tests will afford valuable data
for the study of different types and characteristics
of prison inmates which differentiate delinquents
from non-delinquents.
When the United States Public Health Service
Hospital was established in Lexington, Kentucky,
the problem of narcotic drug addiction was
put under the banner of medicine.
Until that time, this problem had been regarded
almost solely as a correctional one.
The hospital, consisting of a group of buildings,
covers an area of approximately 12 acres.
The buildings are constructed in quadrangular
form, providing a large central court serving
as an entrance plaza to the various departments
and units of the hospital.
From here one gains access to these units,
especially provided for the reception and
treatment of new admissions,
for the treatment of those suffering from
inter-current diseases, and for the intensive
study of patients and to those requiring special
forms of treatment.
This part of the institution constitutes the
professional center of the hospital.
To meet the needs for a better treatment for
drug addiction, special studies of patients are necessary
The hospital is fully equipped and adequately
staffed for this purpose.
Opportunities for outdoor work are afforded
the patients through the operation of a thousand acre farm.
These farm activities include the operation
of a modern dairy,
the raising of hogs,
and poultry,
and intensive truck farming.
Indoor work for patients includes the operation
of a laundry,
a modern garment shop for the manufacture
of clothing worn by the patients not for sale,
and other activities that are necessary for
the maintenance and operation of the hospital.
Supervised outdoor recreation is desirable
and necessary for the health of the patients.
It promotes good fellowship and normal human
relationships.
The career officers of the Public Health Service
constitute a mobile sanitary corps whose members
are available for service whenever needed
in the United States or foreign countries
for epidemic duty, for quarantine duty, or
for investigation work.
The honor roll contains the names of many
men and women who have contracted diseases
in line of duty, and of many who have made
the supreme sacrifice.
These workers conducted their investigations
fearlessly with full knowledge of the dangers
that confronted them.
They've dedicated themselves to humanity and
made their sacrifice on the altar of science.
Other workers were not less fearless, but
more fortunate; not less assiduous in their
devotion to duty, but more favored on the
field of battle.
The Public Health Service conducts its relentless
fight against disease silently and steadily,
no martial music to inspire, no tumult or
shouting to sustain.
The battlefield is silent.
But the grim fight, the personal danger, the
satisfaction of accomplishment are there,
even though the fight is frequently directed
against an unseen and an unknown enemy.
[Music]